Let's create a blog, from scratch, and publish it to the web on Quarto Pub.
So inside the RStudio IDE
New project, new directory
New Quarto Blog
And then create that new session
going to let it switch over to the new environment.
And now we're going to test building the blog.
Quarto has gone ahead and created a bunch of different files.
These create the quarto blog and all the "hello world" examples.
You can see those locally by clicking the the build tab.
Render website
That will build the blog and you can see that we have a functioning blog in the preview.
Post with code (blog post example), you can see we have an about me page.
we can work with this locally but we can publish this to the web
inside rstudio I can go down to the console pane
Click over to the Terminal.
To the Quarto Command Line Interface (CLI)
And type quarto publish
This is going to provide me with a few options. you can publish to Quarto Pub which is a free service we provide.
I'm going to do that because I already have it set up.
It's going to ask which account you want to use. I'm going to do that because I already have an account.
But if you don't have an account it will ask you to sign up.
Press enter and it's going to publish that to Quarto Pub with a specific name
in this case test blog 2
I'll click enter and it's going to use all that information and put it to the web.
while it does this it's going to build the website again,
all the blog posts all put together, re-render all those different components, and then ship it out to the wild.
in the span of this little speed run, we can go from no blog, to new blog, to blog on the internet, and go and look at and share it
and now we have a blog post to share and a blog we can share with the world
to learn more about using quarto, as a computational notebook, for technical and scientific communication pls check out the resources at quarto-dot-org.
THANKS!